there were two units operating at the
heart of government during the pandemic
which were scouring the internet Twitter
Facebook and everywhere else newspapers
looking for views that they consider to
be disinformation about covet they were
and it was set up based on legitimate
concerns about conspiracy theories
spreading about vaccines we've all seen
those on the internet we've seen some of
that damaging content but what happened
was these units cast their Nets very
wide and what they did was scooped up a
lot of dissenting views on the internet
people saying quite legitimate things
about the government's response to the
pandemic about the closure of schools
for instance requiring children to wear
masks in schools lots of the stuff that
we now consider to be a fair game in
terms of talking about the impacts of
lockdown and what happened during the
pandemic and the policy decisions that
were made
those people had their content Flags
inside the cabinet office and inside
dcms in Whitehall and then that pieces
of content were then passed back to
Twitter and Facebook and the government
told them we think this breaks your
terms of service and you should take it
down